I still am I am the Virgin really yeah
there's only a handful of people that
know talked about how not many people
knew even some people in your family
that you're a virgin what's it been like
for you to have these revealing talks
which I'm sure the show has brought on
has it felt relieving how does it feel
for you so relieving I can't tell you
how many athletes and players and former
teammates that have reached out to me
said man I wish I knew you were going
through this I was going through
something similar and for me to hear
that means the world because that is
where I felt the deepest and the darkest
it's at those times so for me to hear
that from them at the world you have
said you're not necessarily waiting for
marriage what are you waiting for in
making that step is it finding the right
woman who you fall in love with or what
is it you know I'm waiting for the right
heart and let me explain that because it
sounds a little corny it sounds a little
cheesy I'm waiting for somebody to match
my intensity someone that's going to be
into me as much as I'm into them
somebody that I'm so madly in love with
and then I could share that special
moment with that's what I'm waiting for
and that's what I'm looking forward to
[Music]
[Applause]
you